- Do you collect pins?
- [D-Rock] You gotta wear one,
I think that'd be funny.
(laughs)
- That's amazing, I will!
I'm gonna bid on one of 'em.
(hip hop music)
Yeah!
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(audience cheers)
I just wanna be happy.
(hip hop music)
♪ I'm 'a keep it triller
than I ever have ♪
♪ Triller, triller ♪
♪ That was yo' girl, that's
why you lookin' sad ♪
♪ I just took yo' bitch, nigga ♪
- Hey.
D-Rock wants more context,
and not like, super like,
(sighs)
36 hours of travel.
But the Jets won, so
it's Tuesday, we left on Sunday.
Backstage at Melbourne,
during this one week trip to
Australia and New Zealand.
Melbourne, Sydney, Brisbane
and then Auckland, New Zealand.
Super excited.
And I'm about to hit the stage,
3,000 people here in Melbourne.
Lower energy than normal
which means I'll probably come out there
a little more thoughtful,
a little more setting up
kind of the tone
and then as the energy
of the crowd gets going,
I'll probably build,
build, build, build,
I think in general, I'm a builder
with my talks.
And I think this one will actually,
just 'cause I'm tired,
will probably start with the
lowest energy in a while.
So,
we'll see what happens.
- [Announcer] Vaynerchuk!
(audience cheers)
(reflective music)
- Do people understand how hard it is
to live your life for yourself?
To live as your own boss,
and make enough money to have a good life,
that's a one percent thing in our society
and everybody has this
level of entitlement
and especially now, trust me,
I'm feeling it.
I'm the beneficiary of it.
But now that we've made
entrepreneurs cool,
the whole thing's totally fucked!
Everybody thinks
entrepreneurship's so easy!
This shit is super hard!
It's super hard to be good enough
to make that kind of money.
Because even though the internet's here
and everybody in this room
has the chance to do it,
the problem is,
the internet's here,
and everybody here has a chance to do it!
And supply and demand takes over.
I love people who are like,
Gary, but my content, it's not doing well,
but it's because people don't get it,
I'm too ahead of the curve!
No you're not, Ron.
You just suck.
(audience laughs)
You're not ahead of shit!
The market is the market is the market.
You have 39 views on your YouTube?
It means you suck.
It means it's not interesting.
Or, it means that you're early.
So many people are like, Gary, I'm lost.
You're not lost, you're 27!
This is a long game.
And the opportunity is substantial.
But there are two very important things.
The world, my friends, let me
let me break it down very simple for you.
The world plays in the middle.
And all the action is in the edges.
(audience cheers, applauds)
- I've been doing the security
for the second time just to see you.
Look, I have confidence.
And I see myself on the Forbes list
in 20 years,
as I see you in the front of me.
But sometimes,
I don't put in the work.
Something inside me is
telling me not to work.
(laughs)
I lay on bed like a stupid guy,
without putting in the work.
- Can I tell you something real quick?
- Yeah.
- The first thing
that comes to mind, for sure,
anybody who wants to be on the Forbes list
is already in trouble.
- No
- No I mean it, I mean it!
I really think that might be
an inside thing you need to think about.
Like, to think about that list
- Unfortunately, my
passion is stock trading
which is all about money.
- Well, it's not
necessarily all about money.
It means that you love arbitrage.
- Where else can you make
trading stocks?
- You enjoy the arbitrage
of knowing something.
Right?
- And enjoy the process as you always say.
- I agree.
Dude, listen, I make money
but it's not
what drives me.
It's a byproduct of my process.
You might enjoy the fact that
you know how to read weather patterns,
and you know how to invest
in agricultural stock,
or that you might believe in Jeff Bezos
15 years ago.
I would not beat yourself up
if you love stocks
to make yourself think that
you only care about the money.
- What if my source of passion is
legacy at palaces and bulletproof cars?
- Well then, do that!
I mean, who gets to judge?
Just 'cause I'm not into that
doesn't mean it's right or wrong.
You do you!
- Alright.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you so much.
See you later.
- Such a pleasure, good luck.
- [Man] My pleasure.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Guilt was my
you know, sometimes I feel like if I
feel like a room really knows me,
I'll take a different angle.
If I'm not
you know me, I'm not
gonna talk about something
that I'm not passionate about.
So,
it's kinda like
having a conversation with somebody
you're encouraging to do something.
You've got to try all
different versions, right?
Encouragement.
I always think about my buddies who
were scared to ask a certain girl out.
I used everything.
First it was building up,
then it was like, you're a piece of shit,
then it's regret.
Then it's like,
whatever gets it done!
The reason I'm so good at what I do
is for whatever reason,
and really, honestly,
I haven't spent a whole lot of time on it.
I give a lot of value to
my circumstance and my parents
as you guys hear but
the only thing you're dealing with
is voices.
What's crazy about me,
if I was in music,
and Jimmy Iovine and Jay-Z
and Beyonce and Clive Davis
and fuckin', all of 'em were
sitting at a dinner right now
and I said, 'blah blah blah'.
And they all looked at me and said,
'you're wrong',
the way my brain works is,
cool.
You're about to really be humbled.
I have a very,
if I believe in something,
I'm just incapable of
hearing anybody else.
And what happens to a lot of people
that do new things,
they do it out of necessity,
not having the resources,
and desperation.
It then works, and then they
try to pander to the machine,
and they lose the edge.
Do you understand?
But if there's something that
I have a line in the sand on,
it's unmovable.
And it's unmovable from the
highest levels.
And I knew,
I was part of a group that
would go visit Barack Obama,
and I remember it was a conversation
in the fuckin' Oval Office.
And I just remembered
that was the time when I was like,
oh okay.
This is forever at every level.
If I'm willing to push back
on everybody in this room.
You know, in that environment
with all these fancy
people and the President
and the government,
well then,
what room am I gonna be in
that I'm gonna succumb to?
And it comes up in other places.
It comes up in
some of you,
you definitely probably know this,
when I'm in the hood,
in a studio,
and I have to go against the grain,
that's probably even harder than
doing it in the Oval Office because
street rules are different than fuckin'
corporate rules or politician rules.
And I'd rather die.
I'd literally rather die
I'd rather die on my own sword.
You know?
(reflective music)
- [Man] Gary, can you explain the
18 hour workday
and slaving for six hours a day?
- If you're desperately unhappy,
and you hate your life,
I'm very passionate that
there's a lot of hours in the day
you can still work your 9 to 5 job,
which is eight hours.
You can sleep six, but guess what?
If you want to say that
your body needs eight,
awesome!
So now eight hours of work,
eight hours of sleep,
it still gets me excited
to debate with people
what are you doing in
those other eight hours?
The majority complain
and watch things or do things
to escape from the realities
of their unhappiness.
And I'm saying, don't hide
or put your head in the sand,
attack those other eight hours
and create content or
create a side hustle or a business
that can change the outcome
of your unhappiness.
I mean,
a lot of times people confuse my message.
I don't think people
need to be workaholics
or hustle every minute.
I'm speaking to the
billions of people who complain
or are unhappy on an everyday basis.
But the fact that we have
this thing called the internet
and you can go garage
sale-ing and flipping
or start an Instagram channel
or a YouTube show,
or a Shopify store,
we have options,
and I want people to see that.
And the reality is,
most people would rather
dwell and complain
or escape.
And I think that's worth debating.
♪ My favorite place ♪
♪ Heart beat drive, to
give my mind a ride ♪
♪ Kick it somewhere you
can catch the vibe ♪
♪ Smoke and getting high ♪
♪ But we still stay on our grind ♪
♪ Show you how I'm living ♪
♪ Yeah we do this every time ♪
(engine)
♪ Kick it somewhere you
can catch the vibe ♪
♪ We smoke and getting high ♪
♪ But we still stay on our grind ♪
♪ Show you how I'm livin', yeah ♪
- So, headed now to
the Sydney talk which is the
biggest of the four talks
on this New Zealand, Australian
kind of tour.
What I'm way more excited about is
the Jamaican bobsled pin
just got a bid at $29.99
which is more than I paid
for the entire huge lot.
If you're not watching Trash Talk,
link it up here, guys,
we're gonna have you,
you're making a huge mistake, literally.
It sucks that we're going into
non-garage sale season.
So it's gonna lose some momentum.
'Cause I do love a good
town-wide garage sale.
That's actually a fun fact real quick.
Just this should belong in
Trash Talk,
but you know I like
my content.
You have to look for
town-wide garage sales.
That's when the whole town does it.
That's how you get to 30 or 40
in a four hour period.
100 in a four, five hour period instead of
driving 28 minutes and
17 to the next one.
Anyway that's a fun fact.
My greatest score for
20 bucks, 40 bucks
I bought like 5,000 playbills.
And when I went through it
I found like three
Brooklyn Dodgers booklets
that went for like a buck 50 a pop.
The original Pinocchio
1940-something movie
that went for a hundred.
Every Betty Davis went for 20 a pop.
Judy Garland's went for like 40 to 50.
- [D-Rock] Where do you find that?
- It was at a state sale on a Friday
in Chatham, New Jersey.
I was on my way to a liquor meeting,
and I saw the sign, I was a little early,
I was like
(mimics tire screeching)
Went in, and I couldn't believe it.
First I found a Huckleberry Hound
1960's stuffed animal for a buck,
I was like, bang, game over.
I was so pumped.
That's a quick 40 on the come up.
But then I went downstairs
and just saw like
80 boxes, and I was like,
what is this?
I knew nothing about playbills,
this was pre-smartphone.
I just went in.
Bought it, took me 20
minutes to load my car.
Bailed on the fuckin' meeting,
drove to my parents' house,
waited for AJ to get out of high school,
and fuckin' spent like
nine hours looking up shit.
(laughs)
Do you collect pins?
- [D-Rock] You gotta wear one.
(laughs)
- That's amazing, I will!
I'm gonna bid on one of 'em.
I'm gonna wear a pin from now on.
A little fun fact about today,
D-Rock had to put tape
on all his batteries
at the airport in Melbourne,
on the way to Sydney.
The other crazy thing is
we didn't have to get our ticket checked.
I was so weirded out.
Nothing.
Love it.
(midtempo dance music)
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience cheers)
Was there ever a time when
you thought that you would fail,
and if so,
how did you overcome that?
- Norman, I think I can potentially fail
at any moment.
That's the beauty of
being an entrepreneur,
you're only as good as your last at-bat.
So, there's always a sense
in the back of my mind that I could fail.
It's why I've always really, really
even though I grew up a
much bigger boxing fan
and I'm still a bigger boxing fan,
there's something I love about
mixed martial arts
is that everybody takes an L.
Right?
It's just like,
and I think that if you're
in business for yourself,
I mean,
how many people here are entrepreneurs
and have been for over
five years successfully?
A lot of us know, it's lonely as fuck!
I woke up at four o'clock in the morning
this morning because there's some shit
going in my L.A. office,
I had to cancel a trip to Hawaii next week
for a conference that I
really wanted to go to
'cause I have to go to L.A. and fix shit.
When you're an entrepreneur,
you own your shit, you're a firefighter!
You're the last line of defense.
I always think I can fail.
It's the reason I'm great,
I think it's like a fighter,
you go in there and you know that
any moment,
even if you're a much better fighter
than the other person,
one punch could change the outcome.
And that's what I think
entrepreneurship is.
I wake up every morning knowing that
one punch that I didn't see coming
can change the outcome of everything
that I've been doing.
And that puts me on an edge
that I like.
I like being awake and focused
and most importantly,
I like that level of humility.
I genuinely, I promise you here
out of every fuckin' person here,
even if you sit here and
your friend brought you
and you didn't like me,
and you think I'm shit,
nobody thinks less of themselves,
nobody thinks less of
me in this room than me.
I mean that.
I am just unbelievably not high
on my own supply.
I appreciate the admiration,
I understand what's happening with me,
but I promise you,
if you could read my insides
on a piece of paper,
I stand up here knowing I'm not shit,
and tomorrow it can all go away
unless I continue to execute,
and I play on that edge every day
and I appreciate and I'm flattered,
but I'm not fucking confused.
(audience cheers, applauds)
Thank you, Sydney!
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Get up here.
D-Rock!
(audience applauds, cheers)
Thank you guys.
See ya.
- [Female] So do you have any tips
on how to deliver an idea
in a way that really
resonates with an audience?
- My framework is,
do you first believe
in what you're saying?
I know that may sound funny
but a lot of people do things
for many different reasons.
Do you actually believe in it?
Do you understand how
you best communicate?
Right?
Is it audio, is it written word,
is it through design, is it,
publicly speaking, is it through video?
And then do you disproportionately
take into account the psychology
of the audience that's consuming it
and the distribution platform
that's delivering it.
I respect the stage
the same way that I respect
the Instagram algorithm.
I understand that there's a platform
that is delivering the message,
and I need to play within it.
And so, for me it's just
respecting all these variables.
- [Female] And one last question.
So one of your number one tips
is to learn how to communicate.
So, could you give me one thing I could do
that I could take away today
that would make me a better communicator?
- I would follow up with people
after you communicate with them.
It's about a feedback loop.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And putting people in a
comfortable enough place
to tell you the truth
is an unbelievably important part of that.
You know?
- [Female] Yeah.
- But asking.
It's a really powerful thing.
I ask so many questions.
Even in real time during speeches
which is unusual behavior
that I didn't know was unusual
it's just my natural state
to try to get feedback.
So, asking people and being okay
with feedback pro and con
and trying to calibrate it in yourself.
But, to me it's just a deep
respect for the audience.
And again,
I'm extroverted in high energy,
so I'm always so worried that
people think that's important.
There are so many people that are
incredible communicators
who are massively reserved.
They just found their
authentic way to communicate.
Right?
(hip hop music)
I don't think people understand
what this level of content and impact
looks like in 12 years.
I'll be a young dude.
I'm gonna be 55 years old!
I'm gonna be a young dude!
And I'm gonna be 55, like this!
(laughs)
You know, like,
it's funny.
- [D-Rock] Not gonna change.
- You know, you look at
how I see it is
I look at rock 'n' roll and hippie guys.
And not that I'm rock 'n' roll or hippie.
But, at 55 they're like the same guy,
I'm like, you're still a burner.
Right?
Or you still got,
you're still rock 'n' roll.
I'm still gonna be
entrepreneurship and hustler.
(hip hop music)
How many gyms?
- [Man] One gym.
3,000 square meters.
So I have like
which are easy to deal with.
But then we have martial
arts instructors that
have
you can't jump over.
To deal with,
we treat 'em all like family,
there's so many things that we do for 'em.
But then they cross the line.
- What line?
- [Man] The drink fridge
and grab a drink and
'I'll pay for that later',
and it never gets paid for.
We have a bar inside and cafe.
- Well there's a couple things.
I understand.
A couple things that I think are
super important to frame up.
There's no such thing as
employees taking advantage of an employer.
There's things that
'cause you're fundamentally in control.
You can fire.
What you're doing,
like a lot of business owners are doing
is you're amortising out the costs.
You know,
treating like family's
also very dangerous framework.
As you guys know I pump
unlimited propaganda about culture,
that's fine.
But, you know,
treating like family
in the way that you're positioning it
is something that I want to poke at,
only because I think
that people can either
get ideological, or
putting makeup on a truth.
Right?
So, a lot of people say,
I treat my company like family,
and I'll look at it carefully
and I'm like, yeah of
course you do because
you're using all these other triggers
to subsidize the fact that you're
underpaying market.
Or you like,
even if you're not underpaying market,
you're doing it 'cause you want retention.
So, you're doing everything
for the business.
And, they don't own the business.
And so, my dad, back to old school,
used to get crazy.
The biggest headbutts my dad and I had
were about the employees.
Period, by a thousand.
The one fight that I never actually won
with my dad,
only out of, like, I
didn't want him to die,
was I wanted to sell all our product
in the store to our employees at cost.
And it just drove him crazy.
So, when somebody steals too many drinks,
you fire them.
I think the one mistake that you're making
in my opinion,
is you're being ideological about
what you do for them.
To me, when you want to do something,
like not have them eat
the spinach anymore,
you make that rule,
and you deal with the
ramifications of people
walking out or not.
Life's about alternatives.
If they can't get free spinach from you,
they can go work at another gym
and get free spinach,
or maybe not.
(hip hop music)